[Music]
hey
everyone welcome to another installment
of harry potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing everyone's favorite
transfiguration professor
or at least everyone's most recent
favorite transfiguration professor
minerva mcgonagall as well as what she
would see in the fabled
mirror of erised in order to determine
what minerva mcgonagall would see in the
mirror
we need to take a good look at her life
she had lots of ups and downs in her
life
involving her career family and love
interests
so it's important that we establish a
sound understanding of what she went
through
to properly assess what she might
actually see minerva mcgonagall is a
scottish half-blood witch
that attended the hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry and later worked
there
her age is actually a bit of a canon
blender because she appears in fantastic
beasts 2
the crimes of grindelwald and appears to
be in her 20s
what's interesting about this is that jk
rowling revealed in the original series
that mcgonagall started teaching at the
school in 1956
at the age of 21. in a 1995 conversation
between umbridge and mcgonagall
mcgonagall reveals that she had been
working at hogwarts 39 years this
december
which is consistent with what rowling
had said initially
while she attended hogwarts she was the
most talented student of her entire year
she achieved top grades in her newts and
owls and showed powerful magical ability
from
a very young age she was the daughter of
muggle robert mcconnell
and which isabelle ross and she had two
brothers
malcolm and robert jr minerva had a bit
of an interesting upbringing
because her father never knew that her
mother isabelle was a witch
after isabelle fell in love with robert
she gave up magic in pursuit of a normal
life
with her muggle love interest isabelle
eventually became pregnant with their
firstborn
minerva when minerva was born isabelle
recognized immediately that minerva may
very well show signs of magical ability
when minerva began to show signs of
magic like summoning toys to herself
and making family cat do her bidding she
knew that she would have to tell her
husband about her background
and she was a witch after isabelle told
robert
they stayed together but their trust
never was the same
which made a huge impact on the family
it was a very sad time for all
minerva's siblings robert and malcolm
would also later prove to be magical
isabelle helped minerva conceal her
magical accidents as a child
inevitable magical occurrences that
would happen to any child learning magic
minerva in time became very close with
her muggle father
and she is said to in temperament
resemble him more than her mother
after finishing school maneuver went on
to work for the ministry of magic
she was offered a position at the
department of magical law enforcement
the department of the ministry
responsible for upholding wizarding law
before starting the position she
returned to her parents home for the
summer
to spend time with her family it was
during this time that she met
dougl mcgregor a clever handsome muggle
who lived in the same town
the two instantly hit it off sharing
common interests
a sense of humor and just an overall
outlook on life
mcgregor would eventually propose to
mcgonagall an offer that she accepted
however after accepting his proposal she
began to think
to brood much like her mother did with
her father
she failed to ever mention to dougl that
she was a witch
she knew that if they wed under these
false pretenses and he ever found out
it could mean that she would go on to
follow her mother's unhappy footsteps
when her mother isabelle told her father
robert that she was a witch
it had a profound impact on the family
their trust
and their relationship minerva
considering all of this
decided that marrying him was not the
right thing to do
the worst part about it was that she
could not even tell him the reason why
if she had told him that she was a witch
it could have been a breach of the
international statute of secrecy
which would have put her job at the
ministry in danger
three days after giving mcgregor her
revised decision
she left for london in pursuit of her
new career this was one of the most
trying times of her life
though she was very much in love with
mcgregor it turned out that he was not
to be the only
love interest of her life after leaving
for london
minerva began working at the ministry of
magic her initial time at her new
workplace was difficult
as she was still suffering from the
decision that she made regarding
mcgregor
at this point in time there was still
more of a distinct divide between the
wizarding and
muggle worlds and there was definitely
more prejudice towards muggles
and muggle borns and minerva who was
very close with her father
and even fell in love with the muggle
did not enjoy this environment
in spite of everything she still
excelled in her work
as she had always been an exceptional
student hard worker
and innately very magically talented she
had earned the attention and respect of
her older boss
elfinstone ercart who would eventually
offer her a promotion
minerva after some consideration turned
the promotion down
missing her home and family in scotland
too much
in an attempt to return closer to home
she applied at hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry
where she was very quickly offered a
posting in the transfiguration
department
under transfiguration department head
albus dumbledore
it was at hogwarts school that minerva
would become the strict transfiguration
professor that we all know and love
she was strict but fair and truly cared
for her students
and their futures when she returned home
she was devastated to hear that her
former love interest
douglas mcgregor had gotten married with
another local
knowing that she turned him away without
ever giving him a proper explanation
she wallowed in her sorrow and knew that
she would have to accept how things had
turned out
albers dumbledore who was her boss at
the time comforted her on the night that
she found out
helping to form the strong relationship
that the two would go on to have
despite leaving her position at the
ministry of magic minerva's former boss
elfinstone ercart would contact her
frequently
what she didn't know however was that he
was actually in love with her
and on one occasion when he was visiting
her proposed
marriage mcgonagall who still hadn't
moved on from mcgregor
had to turn down a gurt's proposal
eventually however
after the first wizarding war had ended
elphinstone got through to her
he incessantly proposed for years unable
to accept the fact that she would not be
with him
when mcgonagall was certain that she was
over mcgregor
she finally accepted his offer they got
engaged while strolling around the lake
near the hogwarts grounds
and the pair would eventually live in a
cottage together in hogsmeade
unfortunately however minerva who had
finally
refound happiness was once again stuck
with tragedy
when elfinstone suddenly and tragically
passed away from a venomous
tentacula bite after this time minerva
couldn't bear to live in their cottage
and moved back into hogwarts school
after elfinstone died
she poured everything into her work and
quietly suffered
a real tragedy so now that we know
exactly what minerva went through
we can start to speculate on what she
might see in the mirror of air said
i've done a few videos of these lately
but i like these videos to be
all encompassing so i'm going to include
a very brief introduction to the mirror
of aerosaid
and explain what it does in case you've
forgotten how the mirror of aerosod
works it's a magical mirror that shows
us the deepest most desperate desires of
our hearts
this is reflected in the mirror's name
no pun intended
as aerosaid flipped around reads as
desire
the mirror itself was made sometime
before the end of the 19th century
and is located in the room of
requirement in hogwarts
engraved on the mirror are the words
erised straw eru
oy to uberu
which backwards reads i show not your
face
but your heart's desire the danger lies
in people losing track of reality after
witnessing whatever it is they've
witnessed in the mirror
they become obsessed with what they've
seen and are completely unable to accept
that for the time
being it's just fantasy and nothing more
it's natural for human beings to desire
things that are unattainable
and even more natural to desire things
period
so almost everyone sees something in the
mirror
i think that the beauty in mcgonagall's
backstory is that it gives us a lot of
ammunition
with regards to what she might actually
see she went through so much tragedy and
heartbreak in her life
so there are many possibilities for what
she would witness i'm going to include a
couple of theories here
my first theory is that mcgonagall would
see herself as a child with her family
when her mother revealed to her father
that she was a witch it had a profoundly
negative
impact on the family dynamic a dynamic
that before that point was beautiful
i think that she would see herself her
mother her father and her brothers
all happy and all unfazed by isabel's
confession
that she was a witch my second theory is
that she would see herself once again
living in the cottage in hogsmeade
with an alive elphinstone urquhart he
would never have been subjected to
poison
and he would be alive and well the two
would grow old together and mcgonagall
would continue with her posting at
hogwarts
but with the addition of a much happier
and fuller home life
and my third theory is that mcgonagall
would see herself in her hometown
married to her first love dougal
mcgregor
she would have professed her magical
background to him and he would have not
been
phased by it the two would be deeply in
love and raise a family in the farm
fields of scotland
i think that this is the most likely
theory because mcgonagall seemingly
displayed the highest amount of
affection
for mcgregor though she did fall in love
with elphinstone later on
it's not indicated anywhere that she was
head over heels for him
which was the way she felt about
mcgregor it has been expressed that when
minerva met dougal
it was the first and only time in her
life that she might have said
to lose her head which for a very
switched on minerva
is really saying something and that's it
for this video what do you guys think
which theory do you think has the most
merit
am i missing anything do you have
theories of your own about this
let us know down in the comments section
below until next time
your wizard ari